(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
- Have a seat.
- Hi.
- I can't get over how y'all are starring
in the same, like, show right now.
Like, it's a modern throwback.
- I'm like the person who,
who brings her
to the dark side.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] I like it,
(Natasha laughs)
your wisdom.
- I'm excited, take me there.
(group laughs)
- I like it.
- Although those nails, I mean-
- Dude, they're look
just like rock and roll.
Yeah, it like, moderns it, I like it.
Well, um, Sarah just got married.
You've been married for a
little under a decade, right?
- I don't know.
(Kelly laughs)
I just keep saying seven years.
- It doesn't matter how long.
So wait. So what, any advice
for her? I don't know.
- Um.
- She said she got proper.
- Uh, advice? I just feel like,
before I had a kid, everything was great.
(Kelly chuckles)
And,
so I guess I would say,
- "Don't have children."
- "Don't have a kid."
But no, you should have a kid eventually,
but do what I did.
Freeze your eggs when
you're 38. Have a kid at 43,
then you'll be bored with everything else.
Then you can like, kind of, you know, go
to this next place.
- [Kelly] Next place?
This is, is this in your book?
'Cause this is great advice.
(Natasha laughs)
- This is my favorite chapter.
- Well, I, you know, my therapist, he was
like, you're a situational breeder.
You'll breed if the situation's right.
So I was like, "Oh yeah,
that does sound like me".
So I, you know, I froze my eggs at 38.
That's the cutoff, ladies.
So. If you want,
- Oh, it is?
- I think you might-
- I think I did that the same,
I might have done that the
same year. 38, when I was 38.
- It's very expensive to
- [Kelly] Yeah.
do this, but you know,
it's like, if you work,
and you know it's like,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
now you can have these two
decades, two extra decades
to make money and have fun
- [Kelly] Yeah.
and live your life and find
someone who you really want
to fertilize, one of them.
(Kelly chortles)
- Um, this lucky, lucky man.
- Oh yeah.
(Natasha laughs)
- So we were talking
about the cover of this.
This is incredible.
Doomsday.
(Kelly chuckles)
This is COVID.
(Kelly laughs)
Like, well, I just love
everything about this cover.
Like, was this really thought-out?
You were like, "This is what I want?"
- This is what I do all day.
I try to be glamorous
in this degrading role
of being a mother.
I mean,
- [Kelly] Mm-hm.
it is really hard to, uh, to
not degrade yourself, you know,
because you're constantly
cleaning, constantly,
like, picking up (beep).
- Yeah.
- And um, you know.
- And you know, doing dishes, chores,
and then people are like,
"The world's on fire",
why are you having children?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But, we can't just let
the idiots have kids, right?
We have to.
(Kelly chortles)
(audience applauds)
(Sarah clapping)
- Right?
- Yeah.
It's really hard because, you know, it's
like, you wanna have a kid
and it was like, I
didn't understand either,
when you do freeze your eggs,
that like, eight eggs
doesn't equal eight children.
- [Kelly] No.
(Natasha laughs)
- No. They can, one can
only be viable. Yeah.
- Right, so I was like,
"Oh, I thought I had eight,"
but really, once they unfroze them,
and then my husband, um, blast, blasted.
I don't know the medical term is.
- I'm pretty sure it's not blasted.
(Kelly laughs)
- Pretty sure that's not the term.
But yeah, he-
- So when he did that,
- He did his magic.
- then there were only four.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And then, so then, they did the testing,
then there were two.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And they put one up, and
that was a miscarriage, and-
- Oh my god. I'm sorry.
- That's okay.
- Yeah.
I talk about it in the book.
That's incredible that you're
open about that. That's hard.
- Well, that's the thing.
Oh, and then my last one, the
best part is my darling child
who I love so much. So it's like,
if I hadn't, if that one
wouldn't have worked,
I just wish I would've frozen two rounds.
I just didn't understand it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But again, that's another reason
why I wanted to write the book,
because there's just so much
about egg freezing and IUI,
and do we test them, and miscarriages,
and just, all these elements
of parenting, geriatric pregnancy.
What, I'm in my early thirties,
why am I being called geriatric?
Like, there's just
- They do, yeah.
- so many aspects to motherhood
that I felt like people hadn't
really been talking about,
and I try to do it in a comedic way.
So you know, it's-
- [Kelly] Thank you,
(Natasha laughs)
from all of us.
Yeah, no. It's, you have
to find humor in it.
I think in any situation, in any kind
of, especially, that's a hard thing.
Like, I actually, that's
a really cool thing,
that you open up about
those serious things.
'Cause I think a lot of
women, they go with shame,
they go with guilt, they
feel, they feel less than,
like a lot of my friends
that it's happened to,
and it's like, that
happens to tons of people.
Like, it's almost like your
body preparing to have a child,
and it's not ready yet,
so it might be ready the next time.
That's like, a common thing,
but it's not a common thing,
I think, people are
comfortable talking about,
so thank you for that.
That's really cool.
- Well, thank you.
- Yeah.
(audience applauds)
- I hope that it's helpful, and-
- Like, we went through something, so
why not share it with others
that don't feel alone?
I think that's really
strong. That's really cool.
- And, and you know,
if men gave childbirth,
we wouldn't know,
(Kelly laughs)
or had to give child, you know.
- There would be no children.
(group laughs)
But also, we would, we
would know all the details.
You know, it's like women
are afraid to even talk about
how do you know the one day a month
that you are very fertile.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I won't say it on here
because I don't want
to, I mean I don't know
if you can say it,
but whatever.
- [Kelly] I don't either.
- Is that stuff you're talking about?
- Yeah, you gotta, well.
- Love where you're going.
(Natasha laughs)
Love the motion.
- I know what you're talking about.
- I guarantee you, nope.
Can't do that on daytime.
(group laughs)
- Okay, I got it.
Well, you'll have
to read the book,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
but I'm just saying.
- [Kelly] What a tease.
(Natasha laughs)
What a tease.
- But it shouldn't be-
- This book offers so much.
(Kelly laughs)
- Knowledge is power.
- It is power. I'm in a,
I'm lucky. I don't know if y'all feel
like you have these kind of girlfriends.
I have very, I don't know
if I have these girlfriends,
or if I force them to be
in this sort of thing.
But I'm very open about everything.
- That's great.
- Like, I'm like,
everything is on the table.
'Cause I feel like I'm
a human, you're a human.
We go through the same things, right?
And if we're not, then maybe
something's wrong with me?
So let's figure that out.
So like, or, do you have those girlfriends
that you feel like you can
kind of talk about anything?
- Oh, yes.
- Yeah.
- I talk about diarrhea all the time.
(Natasha laughs)
- There you go.
There you go,
- All the time.
- sometimes it happens.
- Sometimes you want
it, sometimes you don't.
- Sometimes, you want it.
(Kelly laughs)
- Well see, that's, that's funny,
because I used to hate
scatological humor, and now
as a kid, they think it's the
most, the toddlers think that
that is the only funny thing in the world.
- My six-year-old, not
a toddler, literally ran
around going, "Oh my god, you're so funny,
my pants came off!", and he just
like, would pull his pants
down, and show me his butt.
And they think it's hysterical.
He thinks it's hysterical.
My daughter, who's
eight, thinks it's funny.
There's so much poop talk in my house.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- They-
- You just have
to be okay with it.
This is, she is 40.
- Am I your child?
(Natasha laughs)
- She is filming
an invisible chastity belt,
and she's just like, she's like,
and it will not happen.
- Lock it up.
(Sarah laughs)
- It's like, it is fun.
It's a blessing.
- Yeah, try and cleaning, cleaning diapers
with these talons.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Note to self,
you are cool, cool girl, and mom.
(Kelly laughs)
- It's so,
- It's like, I have no chance
right now with my nails.
Um, we have to stop
for a commercial break.
Look for Natasha's new book,
which has literally
everything, um, it's called,
"The World Deserves My Children",
and it's out now.